bonjour ludovic emmanueli merci d'être
avec nous cet après midi sur rt france
alors l'avocat de laurent gbagbo le dit
lui-même l'application du jugement
dépend du bon vouloir de l'état ivoirien
y at il une chance de voir laurent
gbagbo sur la ligne de départ le 31
octobre prochain
bonjour et bien écoutez réponse très
difficile les élections auront lieu le
31 octobre
je vois pas comment matériellement il
pourrait être reconduit enfin conduit
dans ces élections parce qu'il ya un
certain nombre de critères qui doivent
être étudiées notamment celui des
parrainages
or les parrainages n'ont pas été
vraiment étudié au départ puisqu'il a
été exclue d'office
alors après guillaume soro laurent
gbagbo pour la deuxième fois en dix
jours
la cour africaine des droits de l'homme
et des peuples désavoue la côte d'ivoire
est ce qu'il y a un problème entre la
cour africaine des droits de l'homme et
la côte d'ivoire
alors je te dire que déjà concernant la
décision qui a été pris par la cour la
cour africaine
c'est fabuleux c'est fabuleux parce que
les africains les institutions
africaines assume complètement ce genre
de choses et ne délaisse pas ne l'aide
pas leur ce genre de décision aux autres
institutions internationales donc c'est
déjà une très bonne chose
ensuite est-ce que la côte d'ivoire
visiblement le président actuel n'a pas
très envie d'avoir un concurrent
supplémentaire et donc fait sera en
sorte que son ex concurrent le président
gbagbo donc ne soit pas présent il ya
quatre présidents qui se présentent
actuellement enfin quatre potentiels
dont lui
laurent gbagbo peut être un obstacle ou
alors ça dépend comment il la joue il
peut essayer de le faire venir par la
suite ou ajournées les élections les
faire se prolonger ce projet dans un
temps plus tard par stratégie politique
alors justement vous parliez de des
quatre candidats à la mi septembre le
conseil constitutionnel a réfuté 40 des
44 candidatures à la présidentielle
d'octobre dont celle de laurent gbagbo
mais validé celle du président sortant
qui brigue un troisième mandat très
content au très controversé
cela peut sembler un peu paradoxal non
oui enfin 4 c'est plutôt c'est plus
difficile de se présenter elle aux
élections en côte d'ivoire qu'en france
en france il faut 500 parrainages en
côte d'ivoire il faut je ne sais combien
de parrainage dans différentes régions
c'est très très complexe en plus ça a
été décidé
on va dire dernièrement par rapport à
une élection et donc c'est extrêmement
difficile pour les différents
prétendants d'avoir pu réunir ce genre
de choses donc il faut il faut aider des
gens qui sont complètement dévoyée pour
leurs candidats il y en a pas eu
énormément qui ont pu avoir le temps de
pouvoir trouver les solutions pour avoir
ces dix parrainages
est ce que vous savez comment est
accueillie cette décision en côte
d'ivoire justement parlé par les
ivoiriens eux-mêmes ils sont gbagbo est
quelqu'un qui était apprécié et qui
était aimée qui est toujours aimé
d'ailleurs mais la réalité des choses va
faire que une décision qui est prise
cette décision pour que gbagbo soit le
soit sur la ligne de départ ne peut être
prise que par le président actuel
on a en côte d'ivoire un président qui a
tout pouvoir qui a vraiment tout pouvoir
et qui décide qui va décider de qui va
se présenter ou pas et à votre avis est
ce que le président actuel justement
peut décider de mettre leur embargo sur
la ligne de départ
alors ça va être un calcul politique ça
a été un calcul politique
l'objectif de du président actuel c'est
de passer au premier tour
alors pour passer au premier tour il
faut que dans l'opposition ils soient un
peu l'opposition soit peu débridé c'est
à dire plus du roi de candidats plus il
y aura une diffusion ddd voit donc on à
bédié ou kkb ou le quatrième candidat
qui seront là si on en rajoute un
cinquième ça peut offrir un choix à
l'opposition qui soit plus important et
donc ouvrir une place au président
actuel au président ouattara
qu'est ce qui va se passer il a eu déjà
une déconvenue avec son ancien premier
ministre qui a été rappelé à dieu comme
tirer les ivoiriens donc maintenant il
va falloir qu'il joue autrement comment
va-t-il jouer en tout cas je peux vous
dire c'est qu'il a très envie d'être
encore président merci beaucoup lui
novik emmanueli d'avoir été avec nous
cet après midi sur arte france rappelle
que vous êtes président de l'om j'ai
croissance peas et expert des relations
entre l'afrique et l'europe merci
beaucoup